hello everyone welcome to the winescape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll
today's podcast is one of those
long-awaited episodes people have been
asking for this one for a long time you
know it's funny sometimes there are some
possible guests who are just so
obviously mindscape guests and I haven't
had them on yet and people are like well
what's wrong why doesn't he have him on
yet they must be feuding there must be
beef or something like that that's not
usually the correct answer it's usually
just that I'd like to space them out I
as I've said many times like to have a
variety and that includes both people
who I know very well and am familiar
with their work and the people I've
never heard of before I got to looking
for podcast guests so Tim Walden is
someone I've known for a long time is a
leader in the philosophy of physics or
what we sometimes call the foundations
of physics so studying not physics as a
philosopher but studying nature as a
philosopher but doing so in such a way
that you're looking at the foundational
Quest questions of nature you're asking
the why questions the Deep questions
you're trying to be very careful and Tim
has done very important work in thinking
about space-time and the geometry of
space-time the nature of time and the
arrow of time I will point to I'll try
to link in the show notes to a wonderful
mock debate that was done in the
foundational questions Institute between
Tim and Julian Barber Julian Barber
famously has advocated the time does not
exist Tim is famously advocated that not
only does time exist but it's the arrow
of time is fundamental not just an
emergent approximation because of
statistical mechanics and what fqxi does
is it has The Debaters flip sides so
Julian was arguing in favor of the
existence of time Tim was arguing
against it and they were both really
really good I gotta say they were both
quite persuasive for the points of view
they didn't actually agree with as well
as being quite amusing along the way but
today we're actually going to be talking
about quantum mechanics in some sense
this can be thought of as a sequel to
the podcast they did a while back with
David Albert talking about quantum
mechanics David and Tim uh are very good
friends that have worked together for a
long time they don't agree on everything
because no two philosophers agree on
everything but they are united in their
skepticism about the Everett
interpretation of quantum mechanics and
so with David on the podcast even though
I'm Pro Everett I want to give the voice
to uh sensible voices on the other side
sensible points of view and so David
explained why he doesn't like the ever
interpretation what we didn't get to ran
out of time was what he does like so
today with Tim we're going to be talking
mostly about bohmian or de broyboam
versions of quantum mechanics sometimes
called hidden variable versions of
quantum mechanics I keep calling them
hidden variable theories as most people
do even though as advocates like to
point out the variables are not hidden
the the extra variables that you add to
Quantum Mechanics to make a hidden
variable Theory are the ones that you
observe when you actually make a
measurement and physicists have not
really got on to Hidden variable
theories they're not very popular but
certain sets of people some physicists
some mathematicians some philosophers
have kept the flame alive and
interestingly as we talk about in the
podcast the Nobel Prize last year was
given to tests of John Bell's famous
theorems his famous inequalities which
were very much prompted Bell's
exploration of these theorems and his
proof of them was prompted by David
Baum's hidden variable Theory which
Belle thought was the best formulated
known version of quantum mechanics Bell
thought we should be teaching it in
textbooks so it's a little weird that
the people who really take these
theories seriously get good results that
later lead to Nobel prizes yet the
theories themselves are not very popular
within physics again and I could give my
reasons for not being a fan of hidden
variable theories but they are as Tim
says about Everett they are absolutely a
serious attempt you know it's something
that you should think about if you care
about these things and so we'll give the
sales pitch for why you should take
these seriously we'll talk a little bit
about foundations of physics more
generally and even a little bit about
the arrow of time and the other thing
that I want to mention because Tim
reminded me of it at the very end of the
podcast is Tim is a uh the director and
and I think his title is director but
anyway he's the founder of something
called the John Bell Institute for the
foundations of physics uh Tim has been
very active not only in doing
foundations of physics but in advocating
for the status of this sub-discipline
within philosophy and physics and the
bell Institute which is located in
Croatia and serves as a place to meet
and talk about foundations of physics is
trying to raise funds to get a permanent
home so they literally have a go fund me
and you can visit the John Bell
Institute homepage at John
bellinstitute.org that will link you to
a donate button you can donate to the uh
permanent home for the John Bell
Institute uh where we're not there yet
we need a bunch more donations but I
think they just started so it's early
days maybe mindscape listeners will kick
in a little bit and with that let's go
[Music]
thank you
Tim Allen welcome to the mindscape
podcast thank you good to be here so
you've been a champion for a little
while of something called the
foundations of physics so I want to ask
you two questions one is what is that
for the listeners out there but also
what's your sales pitch like
hypothetically if you're talking to your
colleagues in a physics department or a
philosophy Department how do you explain
to them why foundations of physics is so
important okay
um oddly enough I don't have to sell it
to the to the philosophers it's a weird
situation you have to sell it to the
physicist
um but it's very simple really
foundations of physics as the name
suggests is a branch of physics namely
the one that asks what are the most
fundamental items
how do we understand the most
fundamental physical structures and
things that there are and that's only
part of physics because you could do
condensed matter physics where you say
I'm just worried about other states or
or the physics of stars and you take for
granted a lot of the micro stuff or at
least how to handle it and then you're
building up from there but if you just
dig and dig and dig and say at the very
bottom what's the stuff that doesn't get
explained in terms of other stuff that's
the foundations and so if you do that in
physics that's the foundations of
physics
in philosophy it's easy I actually just
gave a talk about this to the
undergraduates at Rutgers because that
is part of what philosophers call
metaphysics or ontology which is again
just the question of what exists asked
at the most generic level
and
if you're a physicalist you think
everything that exists is somehow
physical if you're not you might think
there are other things that aren't
physical but everybody pretty much
agrees there's some physical stuff not
everybody says not everybody of course
all every time you say something you can
think of a counter example unfortunately
um now the Curious Thing If I describe
it that way is you say but why should
you have to sell this to the physicists
why isn't this just part of the physics
curriculum
and that has a very strange and
disturbing sociological answer that
really goes back to Quantum Mechanics
because
they didn't really understand when
Quantum when the quantum mechanical
formalism was first developed in a way
that was very predictively successful
they really didn't understand what they
were talking about they the physicists
they the physicists the the physicists
who came up with the math
um and you can come up with math and
understand how to manipulate it to get
predictions but still not look at that
math and be quite sure what the physics
underlying it is and those were very
good questions and they were asked very
rigorously uh and vociferously early on
by people like Einstein and people like
Schrodinger people who were very deeply
involved even in the development of the
theory
but at a certain point another crew led
by Bohr and to some extent Heisenberg
kind of said well don't ask those
questions either because for some deep
philosophical reason they're not good
questions although they sound pretty
good or eventually this morphed into
what people call shut up and calculate
where you don't even explain you just
say don't ask those questions I mean my
impression would have been that
Boren Heisenberg were more like we've
told you the answer to those questions
and then when the Americans got hold of
it it was like just don't even ask those
questions that's my take on it was that
it was I mean boar Bohr's background was
in neo-kantian philosophy he actually
said very very very mysterious things
um and I I would say early on the idea
of of the Copenhagen school was say some
incomprehensible stuff and then
calculate and then when it came to
America they cut out the first step
good and
so but you said sociological reasons I
mean I can imagine why well don't let me
imagine what is in your opinion the
sociological reason why physicists would
stop asking what is going on at the
fundamental nature of reality
so and I'm speculating here when when
they first started everybody's familiar
with this picture of the atom as a kind
of planetary system with a nucleus and
then these electrons whizzing about it
we still kind of picture it that way uh
and that was sort of what was called the
old quantum theory
said that and it said by the way these
electron orbits are restricted they
can't just orbit any way anywhere where
a planet can they're restricted to these
particular Little Orbits and then all
they can do is jump between them and
when they jump between them they'll
either give off or or absorb some light
and there was a bunch of explanation
that you could get out of that basic
picture but if you pursue that picture
the natural question is what but how do
they jump I mean what you know how does
it get from here to there and and how
does it orbit when it's in one of these
orbits in questions like that and they
kind of work beavered away at that and
couldn't make much progress on it and I
think they eventually got to the point
where they they didn't want to say yes
those are good questions which we can't
answer
and they were satisfied that they were
calculating correctly and in order not
to say
there's really deep questions we don't
know the answer to they said no no we've
got it we just have the mathematical
formalism the only reason you're puzzled
is that you're trying to push some
classical picture on the microscopic
realm and it doesn't belong there and
your confusion is arising from you
having
um unjustified desires for comprehension
I have I don't know if I've ever
mentioned this to you I have
talked to fellow physicists and and I've
opined that despite everything I
personally care about more than just
correctly predicting the outcomes of
experiments I actually care about
talking about reality and many of them
are very open and explicit that all they
want to do is predict the outcomes of
experiments yeah and I think it would it
if somebody had a lot of funding and a
lot of time it would be interesting to
figure out at what point these people
started saying that because my
experience is that young people going
into physics care a lot about trying to
understand
and they get very upset and I know this
because I teach foundations of physics
in the philosophy department and I get
physics students who say this is why I
went into the field you're talking about
the stuff I was interested in and I
think in most cases like I can't imagine
you know an 18 year old saying I just
want to calculate right so I think that
basic curiosity
about the world gets beaten out of them
yeah um and I really think it's part of
a physics education unfortunately to
beat it out of you so we talked about
Einstein and Boris at her but it's still
more or less true you say I that that's
my impression I certainly can testify
that lots of physics students
will come to me and say I get very
frustrated I raise questions to my
physics professors
of the form what's really going on here
and I'm not told these are good
questions right I really am told don't
ask them don't don't spend your time
thinking about this and slight
generalization but the philosophers to
their credit have kept the flame alive
they've been thinking about these things
yeah yeah it's for it you know it's the
same way that Aristotle kind of had to
be squirreled away in the Islamic world
for a while and then eventually found
his way back you know yes I do think
that that really philosophy has been a
refuge
um and in some cases as you know like
David Albert got his degree in
theoretical physics at Rockefeller his
background was not in philosophy but
he's in a philosophy Department because
these questions were welcomed in
philosophy departments and not welcomed
in physics departments now my feeling of
a lot of people around us and I have
some concrete reason to believe things
are getting better I actually got an
email kind of out of the blue from a
chair of the physics department who said
we're thinking of trying to introduce
foundations of physics into our program
can you give me advice about you know
what we might teach and how it might be
done this was great and this was
somebody I'd never met just you know I
was literally just yesterday talking to
an undergraduate thinking about grad
school and she wasn't sure she likes the
foundations of physics so but she's a
physics undergrad so she thought it'd be
better to go to a physics department for
grad school I was asking for advice on
where to go and it was hard for me to
even
come up with departments would let you
do that right right but maybe it's
changed yeah and you know and at a
certain time I guess that you could say
well you could go here because yes it's
a normal physics department but at least
one or two people on the weekends and a
little bit hiding from their colleagues
are interested in these subjects and
we'll we'll talk to you about them if
you catch them you know off their clock
um all right so there's our sociology
but you already opened up uh the doors
to what we want to talk about which is
these mysteries of quantum mechanics and
David Albert was on the show uh uh David
Wallace was on the show we were mostly
talking about entropy in the arrow of
time Adam Becker gave us this wonderful
historical introduction but when we were
talking to David Albert uh mostly we
criticized the Everett interpretation of
quantum mechanics I say read we being
the royalty I was defending it I I
always let the guests talk so David gave
his Spiel so whatever but we didn't get
time to get into is okay then what
instead so if if put let's not talk
about Everett today unless unless it
comes up I want to be like uh
substantive and proactive and and
constructive what do we do if we're
thinking about what are the what are the
Mysteries we're trying to solve about
quantum mechanics that got us into this
trouble and what are the Avenues open to
solving good so um
that's a really good question and there
are several different dimensions to it
but let me start with the dimension and
I am going to briefly
um bring in Everett but then let it go
uh everybody knows there's this
experiment they say a thought experiment
although you could do it it would be
cool to do it that Schrodinger talked
about
um with this cat that penned up in a
cage with a with a bit of radioactive
material and a geiger counter and this
diabolical device
um actually that turns out that
Schrodinger was really just
reconfiguring the same thought
experiment that Einstein had written to
him just before which had to do with a
keg of of uh gunpowder that either would
or would not explode in the next half
hour and you could calculate a quantum
mechanical probability for it to explode
and not explode and what Schrodinger was
pointing out and what what Einstein was
pointing out is is it if you hold
two views which are very natural views
you would like to hold
you got into what seemed to them to be
hopeless difficulties and the two views
were first of all
when we do quantum mechanics we describe
a system with a thing called a wave
function mathematically
one of the questions is okay that wave
function does it provide us a complete
description of the system meaning every
physical fact about that system one way
or another could be extracted if you
gave me the wave function and this was
when when Einstein podolsky and Rosen
wrote in 1935 and this is the same year
as the cat paper and the cat paper was
really a response or a reaction is
better to say to the epr paper the title
of that paper is quantum mechanical
description of reality complete this is
what they were looking at and they were
arguing in that paper no
um there's more there's more to the
world than wave functions
if that were true of course then as a
physicist again not as a philosopher but
as a physicist the question is okay what
else is there tell me about the other
stuff so so there's one question is the
wave function complete and then there's
the question about how the wave function
evolves Through Time what its Dynamics
is and there's it Schrodinger wrote down
this wonderful equation that has his
name that has some nice mathematical
properties particularly linearity
and people certainly wanted to say at
least part of the Dynamics is this
Schrodinger evolution
and you might say well why not why not
just go whole hog and say all of it is
frozen Revolution that's all it ever
does okay I like that idea that sounds
promising yeah so if you put those two
together and you say a the wave function
is complete and B it always evolves by
Schrodinger Evolution then you get into
this problem that Schrodinger was
pointing out and that Einstein was
pointing out which is that
for the cat or for the gunpowder after
an hour
the wave function doesn't tell you
either yes it has exploded or no it is
not exploded or yes the cat is dead or
no the cat isn't dead the way the wave
function goes into this
we call superposition of different
states which normally you'd associate
one state with the exploded gun powder
and another with the unexploded but what
the wave function gives you is not one
or the other but a kind of combination
of both and if you say well that's a
complete description there isn't no
further fact
that's left out then you say but but
then the cats neither alive nor dead or
the gunpowder is somehow you know weird
suspended State between exploded and not
exploded and you know Schrodinger's
view of that was that that was
ridiculous
um and John Bell when he writes about
this I mean the way he sums this up is
he says either the wave function as
given by the Schrodinger equation is not
everything or it's not correct
and
Everett now I'm just going to say the
one thing about Everett is an attempt to
say no it is both everything and correct
I came up with a way to make it both
everything correct right so I I would
say that's the root that leads you to
the mini worlds Theory and I you
understand the motivation it's to keep
both of those nice things but it has
this price to pay in terms of saying you
know the idea that that one cat you put
into the cage it either ended up alive
or dead no that's not right
there now you know and and not just two
cats actually infinitely many cats
people don't point this out that the
there might be only one live cat but
they're going to be a whole lot of dead
cats because the thing could have
decayed at all these different times
um now if you don't want to go that way
and so we won't spend our time talking
about the price you have to pay and what
you have to do I suppose let's let's
just get our cars on the table for the
audience purposes you're not a fan I'm
not but it's a serious attempt I mean
you have to be very clear here
there are things I'm not a fan of but I
appreciate the honesty of people who are
fans
if they see the what they have to
confront and they you know
straightforwardly say yes I I by making
these commitments I inherit these
problems and I'm going to work on those
right and and nobody should just turn
their back in my view
on a serious proposal I take it to be a
serious proposal I think there are other
proposals out there which I will not
name right now which I do not think are
serious I don't think that they have any
chance uh I would not put many worlds in
that basket gotcha okay
um but if we if we take off the table
having the wave function be both
complete and always Schrodinger then
your options are all right if it's not
complete
then there's something else in the world
beside the wave function and then
immediately you you ask okay what is it
and what does it do and and why am I
talking about wave functions anyway and
things like that those are the natural
questions you ought to have answers at
your fingertips or if you say
um well I think something went wrong
with the Schrodinger Revolution then you
can say well I think the wave function
doesn't always evolve in this way it
does this other thing that people call
collapsing right or reducing that looks
very very very
unshrodinger-like this was the way that
when John Von Neumann wrote down his
understanding of the mathematical
foundations of the theory had two
processes for the wave function the
Schrodinger process and a collapse
process and that's also kind of okay at
a very high level but if you as soon as
you say that you also now inherit an
obligation to tell me all right well
when and how does it deviate
from schrodden Revolution and you there
are lots of details that can be put in
in different ways and different
suggestions
um
some people think early on that the
collapses had to be triggered by
something so things would go nice
Schrodinger wise until X what's the X oh
until a measurement is made an
observation is made and then that of
course astonished this is something
Einstein was very upset about
um other people were upset about because
they say look it's what do you mean an
observation I mean who can do the
observing you know can a mouse observe
can a can an amoeba observe can they you
know trigger a collapse of the wave
function if you go that direction in a
certain way you end up with vigner who
says oh we have to talk about
Consciousness and now you're in the
mind-body problem and you know you're in
a mess
um other people have said well no
there's a kind of Trigger or something
that affects collapse but it's not
measurement or observation it's like say
gravity I mean this is something that
Roger Penrose has been advocating for a
long time not with as much precision as
a theory some other things but that
somehow gravity
which is the one thing that is not well
understood Quantum mechanically may come
in here as
triggering
this non-shroginter Evolution and then
there's another idea which is that no it
collapses and nothing triggers it it
just it just happens it happens randomly
from time to time at a certain rate in a
certain way this is called the
spontaneous collapse theories and
there's a famous Theory by gerardi
Romanian Weber the grw theory and they
just put numbers to it I mean this was
the great thing they did they didn't
just wave their hands they said okay
yeah it collapses every now and then how
often well once every you know 10 to 15
seconds per particle you know and and
how does it collapse well there you
multiply by a gaussian of this width and
you know put some math to it this was
what this is what John Bell was so
impressed by I know when I talked to him
about that theory was that okay for many
years people have had this kind of
General thought
but they took the step of turning it
into clean mathematics yeah and also
clean mathematics but a real Theory
physically right yeah not just an idea
not just the general suggestion that's
right and it can be in fact
experimentally tested yes it does it
makes because the wave function
evolution is different and because the
predictions really depend on what the
wave function does it will make it's
easy to see in principle it makes
different predictions it's harder to
come up with the experimental situations
where you can see those differences
although people have been working at it
for some decades and making progress the
progress is mostly ruling out the theory
I mean so far we have not seen a
signature that the theory is correct
okay we haven't ruled it out but but you
could have ruled it in if you'd seen
certain things you could have really
ruled it in it has not been ruled in and
ruling it in these these spontaneous
collapse theories would count as
falsifying these others that's right if
that were to happen then the other
things on the table that we might talk
about including Everett would would you
know a lot of the motivation forever
would go away because one of the
motivations is but gee this children's
Revolution is so nice right so that is a
motivation I guess the to a physicist
the there's an uh sort of I don't want
to say intuitive but emotional objection
to these spontaneous collapse theories
like it just looks so ad hoc that the
wave function just does this and I guess
you could say yeah but we're fitting the
data yeah and and ad hoc I it's not that
I don't have some sympathy but when you
realize how difficult these questions
are and the weird extremes that people
have gone
to say oh but I don't like this one
because it's ad hoc that is such weak
key right I mean get over it you know I
mean it it the the you know the physical
world might look a little more ad hoc
than you prefer you really shouldn't
rule things out in a strong way for that
reason I mean I guess maybe following
what you said about uh Einstein and epr
the one thing that you can say about
quantum mechanics is that someone's
gonna have to give up on something that
they really want to be true yes I think
that's correct
um I mean
someone yes someone is that I'm not sure
I I would say and and now I'm going to
you know tip the hand which you'd
understand already if you already know
I'm not that sympathetic to the many
worlds because of the problems I see
there and and I also have this feeling
that I can only say by saying the
collapses don't smell right to me right
I don't want to put too much weight on
that but that's just the way I feel I
mean when you're in this you kind of
make a judgment about what looks more
plausible to you then we have the last
possibility where okay yeah there are no
collapses I agree I like the schrodden
revolution it looks it's clean it's
pretty it's linear uh I want to keep
that but I want my cats to just one cat
goes in and one cat comes out
um
that means I have to have something in
addition to the wave function and now
the question is what and the amazing
thing and I think anybody whatever you
think about the theory is at least just
for the non-relativistic theory there's
some complications further on
for the non-relativistic theory this
thought occurred immediately in 1926
already by Louis de bruyne and you say
what is this magical thing you're going
to add to your physics answer particles
Point particles just the sort of thing
you were already familiar with the sort
of thing
um even Democritus well his were a
little thick right they had the shape so
these can be Point particles so they're
even slimmed down and more minimalistic
than democracy and particles but the
idea okay there's some particles and
they move around and they constitute
cats and tables and chairs and if you
want to know whether your cat's alive or
dead tell me where it's what its
particles are doing and I'll give you a
good idea right
um You might say that's such a simple
idea it couldn't possibly be the case
that you just add some particles and
write down a pretty simple looking
equation for how they move and
everything comes out right but amazingly
in the non-relativistic theory it does
uh I don't really see that as giving up
on anything I mean because the the what
you have to give up on is the
completeness of the wave function but
it's not clear what the motivation for
believing that ever was except
bore and so on saying look we know what
to do with the wave function if it's
complete then we're done
and we we want to be done so don't tell
us there's something else right so so in
other words the basic idea is when we
invented quantum mechanics we started
saying oh electrons are like waves right
they they have interference patterns
under the right circumstances they
spread out in the atom
um they are also like particles in
certain ways we we measure little dots
on screens and the brilliant
breakthrough from debris is that's
because they're both at the same time
yeah or or to put it as as Belle again
I'm always quoting John Bell he says
people were as it were you know breaking
their heads all the time wave or
particle wave or particle you'd hear
wave a coal right it's a New Concept you
don't have and he said Why didn't it
occur to them the simple answer wave and
particle right there there is a wave
that is a thing that obeys a wave
equation which is why you get
interference that's the wave function or
the quantum State the thing described by
the wave function and in addition there
is a particle which always has a
location so if you ask but why do these
little individual spots form on my
screen it's because that's where the
particle hit
um no reason why you can't explain the
wave-like behavior because there is a
wave and the particle-like behavior
because there is a particle and that and
their Dynamics is coupled in a way
that the particles are Guided by a
wave-like thing and so the interference
in the wave will affect where the
particles go so this table in front of
us is in some legitimate sense made of
particles and the positions of those
particles are among other things being
Guided by the wave function yes are they
separately interacting with each other
the particles well of course the word
interaction here is one of those words
that
um
different physical theories will give
you different accounts of what even
counts as an interaction
um certainly the particles can be in a
situation where what happens to one will
make a difference to what happens to
others right so the theory will just
tell you
um gee if you you turn on a magnetic
field over here and now this particle
gets deflected down and by the way that
particle you know uh uh will get
deflected up I mean I'm I'm the example
I just gave you is a little bit
misleading but now is that an
interaction between the particles well
it's certainly mediated by the wave
function right the particles can't do
anything to each other
but in a way already you have that in
Newton you say well how does one
particle affect another gravitational
well not sort of directly but you need a
gravitational field or something like
that there's a mediator there's a
physical mediator that accounts for
these relations between what they do
um
is that interaction it's it it is but
it's not quite like
classical Newtonian interaction
um one way to talk about this people get
a little bit maybe this will help or
maybe not but let me say it briefly if
you've studied any physics if you did
any Newtonian physics you'll remember
that the fundamental equation is f
equals m a where a is the acceleration
and the acceleration is is is the change
in the velocity and the velocity is
already the change in the position so
it's a second time derivative and what
that means for Newton
is that to give you the initial
conditions of a system I both have to
tell you where everything is and what
its momentum is all right so I need both
position and momentum and then the
fundamental kind of physical interaction
through f equals m a is changing the
momentum
yeah
but in this Theory it's not like that
um It's A first order Theory everything
is just done with one time derivative
so the initial condition only has to be
the positions and then what the wave
function does is guide the particles it
doesn't push them around in by producing
Newtonian forces on them it guides them
it it as it were determines where they
go more in the way this is a kind of
analogy that uh that David Baume used to
use as if you were piloting by radio
control a little boat out on the lake
and you say yeah you as you turn the
dial you're as it were sending
information or telling the boat where to
go but you're not pushing the boat
around
right and in fact if if the boat goes
twice as far away so your radio signal
is half as strong still as long as it's
getting the signal it's going to guide
it the same way right whereas the
Newtonian Force you'd sort of think well
the further away you get the weaker the
force has to become so it's a different
fundamental picture of physical
interaction and I think many physicists
object to it or you know have this
intuitive emotional response to it
because the wave function is guiding the
particles but the particles don't
influence the wave function at all right
maybe part of that negative feeling is
that they're still thinking of the wave
function as a Newtonian force field they
they might be thinking that this is an
objection people have raised quite
explicitly that this Theory violates
they call the generalized Newton's Third
Law of action and reaction right so they
say oh well in general I think if a has
an influence on b b should have a back
influence or a reciprocal influence back
on a and that I have to say strikes me
as just silly
um I mean in a certain way if you you
say to Newton look doesn't the law of
gravity somehow affect what particles do
he'd say yeah yeah and you say but what
are the particles do they affect the law
of gravity no of course not right the
law of gravity doesn't change because of
what the particles do
um what the way the particles behave is
is accounted for as that were by the by
the law so we don't usually think that
if a affects B B has to have a
reciprocal back effect on a
um lots of cases where even in physics
we wouldn't say that at all so this
seems to me to be a bit special pleading
of trying to find something to complain
about I mean certainly it sounds like a
very made up metaphysical principle okay
that they just made up okay you
mentioned David Bohm tell us his role in
this story so it's an interesting I mean
the the history of this is very
interesting because again people were
very concerned there was the early
quantum theory by Bohr which had this
very classical looking idea of this
planetary atom and then these jumping
kind of jumps which were unusual and
they didn't quite understand and then
the new quantum theory was developed in
the 20s mid-20s and the mathematics of
it came out first Matrix mechanics by
Heisenberg and then wave mechanics by
Schrodinger I'm just throwing some names
out but people have heard these names
but they had the math in a way they kind
of knew how to manipulate the math to
make some predictions but it wasn't at
all clear what the physical picture was
right what's the physical Theory here
and de bruy early on looks at this and
says well I can just I can just put
these particles in these Point particles
and have them guide it around by this
quite simple equation the you need a
second equation because we needed an
equation to tell us what the wave
function does and we're just going to
keep Schrodinger's equation for that so
we got that no real dispute about that
then we need a second one which tells me
what the particles do and that's going
to be a thing called the guidance
equation
and just from mathematical Simplicity
and other very basic physical
considerations I think I've seen claim
10 different ways that would lead you in
in the non-relativistic theory to a very
simple obvious equation guidance
equation for this so lots of ways to
motivate it you know intuitively and uh
so debris discovers this and he presents
it he was very young at the time and
some rather bad objections were made to
the theory but Dubois on his feet
couldn't answer them and this story
seems to be that he was just a bit
traumatized by the whole thing because
these were the big shots of physics I
mean he's a young guy he's at the Solvay
conference with the biggest names
Einstein is there four is there and so
on and you know they're probably whoever
they're beating up on him and he just
kind of seems to have abandoned the
theory a bit
uh as far as I can tell and I've heard
people tell me this more recently who
looked into it
um it kind of lays fallow now Einstein
who we know didn't like
the Copenhagen understanding of quantum
theory we know played around with this
Theory or very similar theories
in the intervening years he didn't like
it but he didn't like it because it had
what he called in a very manifest easy
to see way spooky action at a distance
that's not a locality so we know why he
didn't like the theory and he he could
never come up with a satisfactory
version to him
um and then but it's very possible that
he came up with the version that other
people think is satisfied exactly he
could have he could have very well had
it and it sort of stayed that way and
then and then the really interesting
situation if we get into this is David
Bohm is now a young physicist very
people very well regarded at Princeton
he writes a book explaining quantum
theory from the kind of Copenhagen
borian point of view
and he's in Princeton Einstein's over at
The Institute for advanced study and
he's kind of saying gosh I I would like
to get my nerve to go ask Einstein what
he thinks of my book right and he's
actually trying to get other people to
approach Einstein and as this is going
on he gets a message from Einstein and
Einstein says I read your book I you
know would you like to come talk about
it
and the story is he goes to talk to
Einstein 1950 51s yeah 51 I think
um
Einstein has read the book and he
Einstein says I think this is the best
the clearest exposition of the
Copenhagen approach that I've ever seen
I mean he was really trying hard but
Einstein raised some objections
and the story is and I think it was
Gilman who tells the story was Bone's
roommate at the time that that boom goes
meets Einstein comes back and he reports
when he comes back I'm back to square
one he was convinced by Einstein's
objections he just he couldn't answer
Einstein's objections he realized that
he really didn't understand what he
himself had written
and within a year he discovers this
other thing which was the same thing
that broy had done and apparently
independently as far as I can tell I
mean I was told recently I haven't done
the research myself but again it's not
hard to find that theory if you're
looking in a certain direction right
right and then he publishes these papers
as two-part paper in 1952
um a theory that introduces so-called
hidden variables into quantum mechanics
and gives you all the right predictions
and this was something that people had
believed had been proven mathematically
Impossible by John Von Neumann
um when van Neumann wrote his book yeah
so this is of course a shock it's like
you're not supposed to be able to do
that and then you look at the paper and
you say wait um it does look like you
can do that and we Now understand
that Von Neumann had made not a
mathematical mistake but a kind of
conceptual mistake which was caught at
the time
um by Greta Hermann
um and people pointed it out but you
know who's listening to Greta Hermann
when when boar and Heisenberg are saying
yeah so in 52 the theory sort of gets
reborn it's you know under bones name
and and boom worked on expanding it to
cover Spin and some other I mean you
know it's a kind of very basic Theory at
the beginning and then you start adding
bells and whistles
um to cover more and more phenomena
and it might still have disappeared but
John Bell became a fan of it right well
Belle it's not that Bell started out as
a fan of it it Bell was a fan of this he
was a fan of saying I understand what
this theory is claiming right there's no
mystery about it there are these
particles there's this wave function
here's what the wave function does
here's what the particles do okay this
is a picture of the world if I could or
lump it and when I first learned about
this Theory and I was very skeptical
about it from Shelley Goldstein Shelley
helped me a lot at one point in our
discussions because I was being very
obstrappers and he said look
surely you'll admit this is a theory of
something
okay it says there are these particles
there's this other thing here's what
they do now just in your mind imagine a
world
as this Theory describes wouldn't it be
interesting if that world looked very
much like the world we live in
which turns out to be true this is
always good advice when people have
trouble thinking about new theories
because they always want to fit into
their own boxes right and if you just
ask what it would be like if it were
true to make progress right right and it
it solved it addressed the problem that
Einstein had raised about locality by
saying yeah yeah so this is what I was
going to say so so Belle and Bell tells
a wonderful story right Belle says when
he first learned quantum mechanics he
was very puzzled by it he didn't
understand what was going on
and he thought
you need to add something to it you need
these additional variables the wave
function's not the whole story and he
said he was told by his physics
professors no no no Von Neumann has
proven it can't be done mathematically
proven you can't add any additional
variables and keep the same predictions
and Bell says at the time he didn't know
any German and the book had not been
translated and so that's where it sat
um he just didn't know why he didn't
understand he couldn't read Von
Neumann's proof but he was told there
was a proof and then Bell says he just
gets up in 1952 and reads this paper
that's been published
and says wait boom has just done what
everybody's telling me Von Neumann
proved couldn't be done something's gone
wrong here he quickly uh uh convinces
himself that the mistake in that case
was on Von Neumann's side but he sees
that the theory has this manifest
non-locality and he asks himself surely
what Einstein must have been asking
himself
can you get rid of it can I have a kind
of theory like this
but without the non-locality in it that
still makes the right predictions the
quantum mechanical predictions that's
the very precise thought that Bell had
and when he finally got some time off on
sabbatical to sit down because he
couldn't do it during his regular
workout
but it's but the amazing thing is of
course when you see Belle's proof it's a
few lines of algebra it's not like you
know proving fairmont's Last Theorem
okay it's not hard mathematically when I
first read about this stuff which was in
in the Scientific American in an article
by Bernard de Espana back in 79 I guess
I it's not looking back on it it's not
the greatest article in the world but it
was enough was there that just with a
little math you could say wait wait I
see the problem right I really this just
stands out at you
um so I the the what happens with Belle
is belt what bell realizes is wait a
minute
no you can't get rid of the non-hocality
out of this Theory you can't get rid of
the non-locality out of any Theory I
mean throw away quantum mechanics and
start from scratch from entirely
different principles Bell's proof is not
about quantum mechanics it's just about
certain experiments and the correlations
that you see in the outcomes
you can't have a theory that is local in
a well-defined sense that won't predict
that
quantum mechanics does predict it and
more importantly than quantum mechanics
predicting it
the world does it right that's why the
Nobel Prize Went to went to clauser and
aspay and Z Islander recently for doing
the experiments that showed that fire
that the violation of Bell's inequality
actually occurs and as you and I both
complained about in separate occasions
the Nobel committee blew it in their
press release yes they did they they
said that what they had done was what
proved that van Neumann was right and
you can't have hidden variables which is
just the irony there is so delicious
yeah because Bell became you know Belle
then became the probably the strongest
advocate of this bone Theory or
Deborah's Theory which is a theory with
additional variables
why because he could say well what's the
objection you can't object as Einstein
did I don't like it because it's
non-local because now I understand okay
the non-locality is just in the world
right suck it up
um and it's a clear Theory and so on I
mean at one point Bell says he's going
through all these different ways of
approaching quantum mechanics and he
says well the pilot wave approach uh
shows the best craftsmanship but then he
says but is that he says then
wonderfully I mean he always made these
cutting little remarks is that is that a
virtue in our time right do people
appreciate good craftsmanship anymore do
they like just things that sound you
know amazing and blow your mind because
it it at some level it's a much more
pedestrian kind of theory you say yeah
there's some particles they move around
yeah there's this wave function that's
kind of funny thing but I'll explain how
it you know how it plays into the
architecture here it was a rough time
for the philosophy of quantum mechanics
yeah in certain ways but okay so um the
I think that there are any physicists
out there who are not into the
foundations of quantum mechanics and
they're listening they're they're very
confused because one uses the word
locality in different senses sometimes I
mean if you ask the quantum field
theorist is their field Theory local
they would say yes it's very very local
so what exactly do you mean by this word
good so and and there's even a technical
mathematical condition that's imposed in
Quantum field theory that they will call
locality uh has to do with commuting
operators
um okay so what's going on well one
thing to say is that there is there's
Bell proved there has to be some kind of
influence or effect if Alice and Bob if
I set up a pair of particles in a
special State called an entangled State
and anybody who's heard about this at
least have heard the word entangled
um but send the particles off way in
different directions so they're you know
hundreds of light years apart one to
Alice's lab and wanted to Bob's lab
um
the intuition of causal locality
basically says nothing that Alice does
can have any actual influence or effect
on what Bob sees
right yeah that doesn't mean there can't
be correlations between what they see I
mean everybody knows if people give this
example you tear a dollar bill in half
and send it to sides off in different
directions of course Alice seeing one
half immediately informs you that Bob
will see the other half but that's not
Alice doing anything that affects Bob at
all that's just trivial it's true
everybody understood that everybody
understands there could be correlations
like that but those correlations are
already explained by what happened at
the source and so nothing non-local is
going on in that case
Bell showed no you can't get the kinds
of correlations you see in quantum
mechanics by that kind of local story
there has to be a sense in which what
Alice does
actually makes a difference to what Bob
sees or the other way around
that's causal non-locality now the next
question that arises is oh could you
implement that in some way to allow
Alice to send a message to Bob signal
Bob right tell Bob whether they're going
to meet for you know lunch today or not
and the really interesting I mean a very
interesting thing is that at least under
a certain pretty
clear idealizations you can kind of look
at the way quantum mechanics work and
say well no actually even though you
can't get rid of this connection you
also can't use it to signal and and the
person who proved that first was also
balanced that people like to call it the
Nobel telephone theorem so he was
perfectly aware of it right you can't
use the non-locality to signal
uh I'm sorry that's a that's a feature
in
Copenhagen Everett Bone whatever you
want to never use well okay now this is
now I'm gonna now I'm gonna tread off
into into treacherous territory it's
five years late okay
um if you say and I think it's just a
bad thing to say that the the
fundamental postulate of say relativity
has to do with signaling
that you can't signal faster than light
and you say oh well then this is still a
local Theory but that just I I think
first of all signaling isn't even the
right kind of concept that should be in
the foundations of any Theory just as
measurement shouldn't and just as
observation shouldn't
um and and you know Bell proved there is
this kind of non-local causation and
maybe I can't use it to signal but so
what
um but then the the next thought is gosh
If there really is this real physical
non-local connection somehow
why can't I use it to signal I mean you
sort of offhand think there must be some
clever way to do it now I'm going to
report something
to ask that question of course you
really need a well-defined theory on the
table in front of you right because you
have to ask well what can I do with this
physics
um
quantum mechanics tends to use these
things called hermitian operators or or
as they call them observables and they
sort of you the mathematics of that is
is what they look into to ask certain
questions but if you have an actual
theory in front of you you're not
restricted in that way you know you can
just say well can I do something can I
twiddle this and you know see something
there
it looks like
in the bohomian theory with spin
there's reasons to believe you could
signal faster than light
oh oh this could be the most popular
podcast ever you weren't expecting that
were you I was not it is it is the I am
con personally I suspected there should
be a way
uh sidhantas who's a young researcher
has been looking at something which
amazingly people had not looked
carefully of at which is in this pilot
wave theory when you add spin okay
that's an additional physical degree of
Freedom people usually just don't fiddle
with it they kind of deal with spinless
particles you know at this level to
understand things when you add spin
and when you look at there's a very
specific thing you can look at that
standard quantum mechanics doesn't have
an obvious way to even treat all right
this is the key to understanding this
that is arrival times
so if I if I this is a well-known issue
yes it is a well-known issue although
people just kind of put it out of their
mind so if I have an electron as they
were confined in a little box which we
kind of know how to do and at some
moment I open the box and then I've got
a screen and at some time a flash
appears on the screen one thing you can
ask is well what was the what was the
transit how long what was the time gap
between when I opened the box and when
the flash occurred and it turns out if
you ask Quantum mechanically and in
quantum mechanics you of course have to
do experiments many many times and you
get kind of statistical results you get
a a distribution of results
it's nobody agrees how even to make that
prediction using standard quantum
mechanics because there is no hermitian
operator that corresponds to arrival
times okay in the in in this pilot wave
picture because you have these particles
and they just move
it's kind of easy at least to ask the
question according to the theory how
long did it would it take a particle
here to get there right so you can
actually do these calculations and when
you do them with spin you start to see
that there's a spin dependence of the
arrival times
uh which you really weren't expecting
but it shows up
and if that's right it's already a
question of whether you'll see that this
is something you could check in the lab
we're trying to find people who'll do it
but you need specialized equipment and
you need the motivation to do it if if
there is that spin dependence of the
arrival times then there's a very quick
argument oh you could signal now the
signaling would be very subtle I mean
it's not like you could flip a switch
and a light would go on there but it
would essentially say if Alice orients a
magnet in her
lab in a certain way Bob will suddenly
start seeing a slightly different
distribution of arrival times than if
it's oriented another way
and that would be any kind of
information right it doesn't have to be
a clean 100 strong signal any signal
right any Shannon information sure and
this suggests that yeah you actually
should be able to do that now there are
lots of still there's lots of arguments
within the community about whether this
is right how far do you have to carry
the analysis uh into the observing
equipment I mean lots of stuff maybe in
a couple years people will say no this
argument breaks down for some reasons we
don't quite understand yet so I don't
want to say this is nailed down no but
it's there because it's a really hot
interesting interesting topic and one
that could be tested in a lab some of it
you could do today I'm not completely
surprised because both you and I have
written papers about energy conservation
and its failure in quantum mechanics
which anyone could have done in the
1950s yeah I just didn't ask the
question but um is this a fact that
you're talking about now would it be a
difference between well-being mechanics
and other formulations of quantum or
it's suggested you can't ask the
question yeah it's a little hard to say
because and again I'm now just reporting
what sidhan tells me and he's done all
the research he says if you go into the
standard physics literature about
arrival times you'll find 20 different
suggestions about how to do it they tend
to agree with each other in the far
field that is if there's a long time
between when you release it and when you
detect it all of these different
approaches
Converge on the same answers but in the
Midfield there are places where they
will not converge
so what can you say I mean there's it's
not clear what predictions the quote
standard approach even makes so you
could say if the if the pilot wave
approach makes a clean prediction it's
clearly a different Theory because look
it's doing something precise where the
Rival doesn't even have anything precise
to say
the other obvious question is you've
been simultaneously talking about
whether you can send a signal faster
than the speed of light but also working
in the context of non-relatistic quantum
mechanics where there is no speed of
light so that's right do we have to talk
about relatives to Quantum field Theory
to have this conversation well we
certainly don't have to talk about it to
have the conversation we've had up until
now because even before relativity
if you said look Alice is in a lab 100
billion billion miles away from Bob
um Can Alice do anything in her lab that
bought that would make a difference to
what shows up in Bob's lab the natural
thought would be no I mean you know
you know even if there was some effect
even if we were fast effect it would
drop off with the square of the distance
it would you know tail off there's you
know so you can have the discussion
about non-locality even in a
non-relativistic now it becomes sharper
in a relativistic context because then
you mean faster than light where there
is a light cone structure there's kind
of an objective thing you mean there
that's very sharp so you can sharpen it
up in the in the relativistic context
but I think you can still reasonably
have it it's not like all of your
discussion of the non-relativistic case
just falls to the floor when you notice
there's relativity my halfway informed
feeling is that well me mechanics looks
quite quite natural in the
non-relatistic regime and it's a little
bit more of a challenge to see how we
should just do Quantum field theory in
that picture yeah there there is no
doubt there there are both conceptual
and Technical challenges when you go
from standard quantum mechanics where
and one of the signals here for people
who don't know is it in quantum
mechanics you talk about a system having
n particles and that's it right unless
you add some or take some away it's
going to be n particles forever
um but that's how the world that's not
the world
um it it we now know that there is some
phenomenon that we call particle
creation Annihilation the particle
numbers can change and so you need to
account for that
um whether I mean there are lots of
subtleties here one subtlety is the
thing we call particle creation
Annihilation is it really
um and and what I mean by that is when
Dirac and he's just a standard guy was
talking about this he didn't have
particles really come into existence he
he said well they're always infinitely
many particles filling up negative
energy states and what we call the
creation of a new electron and a new
anti-electron a new positron is really
just lifting an electron that was there
all along in a negative energy State up
into a positive energy state and leaving
a hole behind and uh the the you know so
it looks like there's a new electron and
the hole is the thing we call the
positron now that's a story that would
account for the phenomena Without Really
creating any new particles it's just
moving them around in energy space as it
were so there's certainly you have to
account for the phenomenon right you
have to account for the phenomena yeah I
can take a a really high energy Photon
and gee they're just you know appears uh
uh now an electron and a positron or you
know some things that that satisfy
certain conservation laws we need to
account for that phenomenon whether it
really deeply requires uh new particles
or do you want to give up the particle
the other thing to say is the pilot wave
picture is not tied to particles it just
says there's something that the wave
function is guiding it could be
particles it could be a more field-like
thing right there's a kind of way of
doing bomian field Theory where you
replace the particles with Fields but
the same kind of architecture
and the other point to make which at
least needs to be made is that people
can say gosh but there's no good foamy
and Quantum filter standard Quantum
field theory has been plagued by
mathematical problems and you know
runaway singularities numbers you try to
calculate and they all come out Infinity
it's not as if it's all you know
conceptual lightness and Clarity in the
so-called standard picture so you don't
want to hold this picture to a higher
standard
of of mathematical precision and so on
then you're allowing for the theory that
you happen to use okay that's that's
perfectly fair but I'm just trying to
get straight for the listeners out there
you know if I'm a particle physicist and
I just calculated the rate of Higgs
bosons decaying the two photons and
something like that is that stuff I can
do just as well in the current bohomian
framework there are is that work in
progress okay so one of the things that
people have looked at is suppose I I
remain again there are different moves
you could make you could say I'm going
to give up the particles all together
and put something else more field like
in uh or you can say no I'm gonna stick
with the particles but I am going to
allow literally the number to change I'm
going to allow particle creation and
Annihilation you can do that that how
you would work that out in a kind of
pilot wave picture was done has been
done for 30 years ago I guess
and what you do is you say in the
original picture you have a fixed number
of particles and all they do is move
around and change their configuration
but now I say no no the reals
space of possible States is there's a
zero particle State and a one particle
State and then two particle States and
then three so this whole
um thing called Fox space which is
familiar to any of the physicists you're
talking about and you say no that's
that's what I'm now going to say the
thing is always in a particular location
with a particular number of particles
sometimes it just moves around in one of
these sectors and the number doesn't
change and sometimes it can jump up or
jump down which corresponds to particle
creation Annihilation I now need a a
Dynamics for that it turns out that
Dynamics tends instead of being
deterministic to be indeterministic the
easiest way to do it is they at any
given time there's a certain chance
you'll jump up and create a new particle
or jump down and lose particles okay you
can do that and what falls out of doing
that is the mathematics of standard
Quantum field Theory okay but so just
just so I didn't lose it among people
who are fans of boomi mechanics right
now
it's there's a camp that thinks maybe
the hidden variables are field like and
there's another camp that thinks maybe
there's just a collection of particles
so we're not sure it's not a leading and
there's a lot of things that are debated
within it so here's another question
people when you start out you're always
treating electrons and gluons as
particles but and they're all fermions
right they're all half
oh sorry I'm sorry um I'm in quarks
um
then people ask well what about the
photon is is that a particle are there
Photon trajectories and it turns out you
can try and develop a theory in which
there are an F theory in which there are
okay and people work on both sides and
there's no agreement in the community
and you ask well what would be the
advantages you know uh of doing it this
way what would be the advantage of doing
it this way so it's a
a general architecture of how to develop
a theory that can be implemented of
course in many different ways and so
even within the big house right there's
rooms in the big mansion of people who
are working in different directions
with regard to the idea of sort of
stepping back from the fields and going
particles as your ontology
two things come to mind one of which is
against that idea one of which is for it
so which one you want me to tell you
first then you can respond which
the worry I have yeah give me the bad
news first something like the Higgs
mechanism where it seems that the Higgs
boson lurking as a field with an
expectation value throughout all of
space is playing a crucially important
role in explaining phenomenologically
observable properties is that something
you could you use I I mean I think I
just answered that which is it sounds
like you're the kind of person who would
say uh I'd rather yeah I'll treat my
pheromones as particles and I'll treat
my bosons as Fields essentially which is
okay yeah I won't I won't introduce
particles associated with the integer
spin objects that that I think would
would make you happy right I don't have
to say there's a Higgs particle right to
work it into the theory and and there is
a reason to think that you're going to
work bosons and fermions in different
can enter into the theory in different
roles okay this is going to undo the
good news that I had so I don't know if
you know this because I only recently
learned it but Richard Feynman when he
was inventing Feynman diagrams part of
his motivation was to get rid of quantum
field Theory and replace it with another
theory particles again and we now think
of Simon diagrams as a tool for
understanding Quantum field Theory so he
he changed his mind but his motivation
I'm told was that cosmological constant
problem really yeah though I did not
know that yeah I mean I was told that I
couldn't I need to find the the
reference for it but the idea is if you
have Fields they all have these zero
point energies and they add up to
infinity or you cut it off and it gives
you a big vacuum energy but if you have
particles you don't have that problem so
if I were a bohmian particle ontology
guy I'd be claiming a solution to the
cosmashical concept
that that I look that's a connection I
was unaware of my my understanding and
again this is not based in in anything
other than what I somehow picked up on
the street
um was that that one way anyway let me
put it this way how Feynman thought
about it I'm not sure one way to think
about Feynman diagrams
which is runs contrary to the way people
often talk about them is that they were
just a mnemonic device right I I have a
mathematical equation that has an
infinite number of terms that I need to
sum up and of course the issue gets bad
when that sum goes to Infinity but
anyway I have this all these terms I
need to add up and that the and that the
diagrams were just easy ways to kind of
remember what the different terms looked
like right
um to figure out what integral you had
to do exactly and now if you the the we
the way I say people don't do that is
they often point at those things as if
they are literal pictures of stuff going
on oh this is doing this and this is
doing this and all the stuff is going on
it's a booming buzzing confusion of
virtual particles that are running
around that talk
I don't think makes any sense on any of
you I'm on your side um yeah so if if
it's just a mnemonic technique then
you're really it's as if I like to say
suppose you wanted to calculate the
volume of a sphere and you just love
cubes and you say okay look I'm gonna
first of all figure out the biggest Cube
I can sit inside a sphere and calculate
its volume and now I've got these other
little you know six round pieces
sticking out now I'm going to find the
biggest Cube I can get out of each of
those and then add those and then more
cubes and more cubes and more cubes and
you can see okay there's going to be an
infinite sequence
of these volumes that you now need to
add up to get the total volume of the
sphere but you'd say but you shouldn't
think that the sphere is this really
complicated thing right it's actually
quite simple and in fact here's another
way to do this calculation that is you
know is straightforward and you don't do
an infinite sum and G it's just you know
four thirds pi R cubed no I think that's
actually an important point because
lots of modern physics is motivated you
know beyond the standard model particle
physics searches for our next best
theory is motivated by questions of
naturalness right and fine-tuning and so
forth and I think I don't know what the
right way to think about those problems
is but I think that not only do people
talk as if there really are virtual
particles popping it out of existence
which there aren't uh but they also
think that somehow nature starts with a
classical Theory and then adds Quantum
Corrections on top of it and nature
doesn't do that and that might change
our perspective here right and I think
there's a I think you're exactly right
and I think there's a methodological
Point here which is that because we
start out learning classical physics and
it feels familiar to us and we familiar
with the math of it there's this great
Temptation if someone says oh the way to
come up with a good quantum theory is to
start with a classical Theory and then
do this thing we call quantizing it
right we put the hats on we turn certain
variables into operators and well most
the time it's clear how to do that
sometimes it's not quite clear how to do
that but you think but this doesn't make
any sense right the the world yes the
world behaves
pretty well the way classical theory
predicts at a certain scale
but that's because something emerging
out of a very non-classical physics and
there's no reason to think that the
right way into that physics is to start
with the approximation and then twiddle
with it yeah right it's got to go the
other way around right you need the
fundamental physics and then hopefully
you can understand why the Quan why the
classical approximations work as well as
they do
um but I think people are tempted be you
know because you have this kind of kind
of algorithmic thing of oh just take a
variable and put a hat on it and turn it
into an operator but conceptually that's
just not the right the right way to
think about it yeah so good I'm glad we
can find like all of our uh points of
agreement against the consensus despite
the fact that we have some disagreements
but
this question of the speed of light I'm
going to go back to the experiment that
the possible signaling because
I I do not know about that work I don't
know whether it's right so that's okay
we're putting it on yeah right there but
the idea of looking hard for possible
experiments to do I think is a crucially
important one I mean my impression is
that your typical bomian on the street
thinks there's no experiment to do to
test boom versus conventional quantum
mechanics whatever that is do you have a
feeling about that I I I do and I this
is a discussion I am in right now
arising out of this work
um that is a lot of people in the
bohomian camp will kind of say oh but we
know that it won't make different
predictions than quote standard quantum
mechanics now I I think that's just
wrong I think they're you know kind of
toy cases that make it obviously wrong
but leave those aside I I just tried to
understand what the argument was and I
can't get it right um and so I think and
I think some of this is defensive right
because there's this and you stop back a
second you see this is so unfair you
standard quantum mechanics whatever it
is anyway you can make lots of good
predictions with it then somebody comes
up with a new Theory and then they say
oh does your theory make any new
predictions if not why should I pay any
attention to it now the first thing you
notice is but wait if these two theories
had been discovered in the opposite
order right you know you would be going
the other way around so this can't be
from a logical point of view a good
objection
that you know why should I take your
theory seriously because it makes all
the same predictions as my theory
because that's you know that doesn't
make any sense
but I think that is an objection that
physicists often made and so you know
there were certain kind of defensive
procedures that were put up to say oh no
we're not saying they're new predictions
right um but and then you'd have to go
on
um
I yeah I my view is a sharp Theory again
standard quantum mechanics has certain
vaguenesses in it
um if you if you have to talk about
measurement if you have to talk about
observation
um because those are vague terms these
are the objections that we had and so
you'd expect a sharp Theory will
certainly ought to differ
in some ways and and you should be
looking hard at where those differences
might be
is so the unfair question what fraction
of the bomians out there agree with you
about that
it's not an unfair question but it's a
sociological question which I just can't
answer I don't know I don't know and and
they're and even the as it were the
Bowman Camp is divided into subcamps and
uh probably the statistics and the
different ones are different and
probably my guess is weirdly enough it
probably correlates with age I think
y'all weird at all I think younger
people are more open to certain things
than people who've been through a lot of
battles
um but I but I really don't know where
are these bomians of which you speak are
they in philosophy departments or
physics departments or well
um a lot of them yeah so
there were a lot of
students
um
in Europe
and I'm I'm sorry this is going to be
just a little hard for me
um that lifter who's at the LMU in in
Munich
had always
a dozen graduate students an
unbelievable what he did that nobody
else I know has ever done to promote
young people and bring them into this
and he was in a physics he was in he was
in the physics he was in the math math
department
um and he was just the most wonderful
caring
Dr fotter and looked after these
students he could not get many of them
jobs in Academia a lot of them have gone
into other you know industry whatever
they they did their work
um
but there are a lot of young people who
came through that program who know it
who know the theory and work on it um
sidhantas who I mentioned was one of of
detlef's last students
um and some of his students a couple of
them are in to begin in German you know
so there are more of them in Europe
who've come through LMU and through his
influence then the other thing that's
happened is a lot of physicists who
realize they're interested in
foundations notice that if you have uh
credentials as a philosopher you can
more literally more easily have an
academic career in a philosophy
Department as a philosopher of physics
than you can in the physics department
so some of them have switched over
um also deadlifts too I mean Dustin
lazarovich who's now in the technion in
Israel
um there there are people who are around
and it's it's more than there used to be
I mean the total number is up what the
effect of losing debt left because debt
left died during covid
I don't know I mean nobody right now is
is doing what he was able to do and we
have to hope that some you know there
was a dedicated person with the right
the right
psychology and and so on can can kind of
take his place and help people along do
you think we started by talking about uh
why you don't need to make the sales
pitch to philosophers they get it yeah
How Deeply do they get it how much has
quantum mechanics changed
what philosophers think about
metaphysics so this is an interesting
question
um in philosophy
I would say there are three camps of
people who do what goes under the name
metaphysics okay I just gave this talk
at Rutgers the undergraduates about
metaphysics and science our metaphysics
and science enemies or friends or what
or the same thing yeah yeah exactly that
was my that was my conclusion at the end
so you jumped right to the end but no
there's an interesting history because
it really there's a certain point where
they're clearly you know they considered
to be enemies I mean carnap and anyway
um
I would say that in in metaphysics
metaphysicians people would
self-identify as metaphysicians in
philosophy now fall into kind of three
camps there's a camp that's sometimes
called analytic metaphysics which tends
to be doing things which don't seem to
care much about science they're asking
questions that don't it's not obvious
that any scientific theory would bear
one way or the other on the question as
an example oh are there I mean these are
these are not just gonna be words are
there universals or tropes okay so this
is the kind of thing that that a
philosopher of a certain kind will
understand and they'll be fighting with
each other forever about Universal and
tropes and it's very hard if you say
well you know did Newton believe in
Universal tropes you'd say well the
Newton didn't care I mean you know this
is not it's just not an issue that that
is built into the guts of that theory in
any obvious way
um then there are
then there's another camp that goes by
the name scientific metaphysics for the
reason of saying that what I think is
obviously correct metaphysics is about
describing what exists at the most
General Scales and if you're interested
in what exists in the physical world you
better pay attention to science not to
say that the scientists can just answer
those questions but they do have
relevant things to say to offer
um
but then that group kind of subdivides
into two the ones who then specialize
say to do philosophy of physics now that
really requires learning some math and
some physics and at a you know
reasonably
good scale some people are you have full
phds in physics you know but you
certainly have to devote some time to
just studying math and physics to do
this in a kind of specialized way and
then there's another group of people
who've clearly acknowledged the
relevance of the physics but they're not
experts and so they like to listen to
The Experts and try and figure what they
can draw out of it right without
themselves delving so deeply into it I
would say that's that's how the
landscape goes and but do they talk to
each other these people or they go to
the same conferences
um I yeah I mean there are certainly
they do talk well they're they're in in
each other's presence
I mean there are a lot of specialized
conferences but there are conferences I
mean I was just invited to be on a panel
at the metaphysics Society of America
and I'll tell you the people in that
Society are not people you'll ever run
and run into and and you know they were
doing a very different kind of
metaphysics but they they were happy I
talked about what I do and the way I
think about it and they didn't throw
bricks at me it wasn't the way they
thought about it they were interested
they were interested yeah they were
interested and they appreciated having
the conversation and I mean philosophers
tend to be pretty open to talking about
weird stuff because that's more of us
comes with the territory whatever
strikes them is weird you still don't
just reject it right I guess what I'm
what I'm getting at and I I'm not trying
to presume the right answer because I
honestly don't know but
to what extent can we imagine smoothing
over the conceptual differences between
thinking about physics and thinking
about metaphysics like it really should
be thinking about reality is what we're
doing right yeah I mean I mean we don't
you know I do need to mention here that
um again you can be interested in
metaphysics and not be a physicalist so
you'd say part of what I do really is
not going to be informed by physics if
I'm a mathematical platonist and I'm
worried about mathematical reality and I
say that's just not part of physical
reality so I don't care how your physics
comes out that's a fair you know that's
a fair thing so not all of metaphysics
has to be hostage oh sure you know or or
or all that interested depends on you
know where you're where you're focusing
your attention Okay
um we actually you know Barry lower was
another uh person we had on recently and
Barry he he said something not on the
podcast sadly but uh in informal
conversation that was even stronger than
something I would say I think he was
being humorous about it but he said he
remembers very vividly being struck the
day he realized that most problems of
philosophy could be cured or solved by
statistical mechanics
and I think that he has a different view
about you than that dude so we're
running out of time a little bit but I
wanted you to give to have a chance to
give a little bit of your view of uh the
the arrow of time and and things like
that which is the other giant thing the
people who care about uh foundations of
physics spend their time worrying about
right
um so let me actually start with the
last thing first and just get it get it
out in the open so people are Auto at
least be aware of it I would say it is
it is kind of everybody has this idea
there's space and it's kind of
three-dimensional at least At Large
scales
um and if I if I talked about say the
north-south direction at a certain point
if I went on to say by the way space
goes north to south it doesn't go south
to North you'd look at me funny and
you'd say what in the world are you
talking about right um the you know the
spatial thing it just it it there are
two directions and they're oppositely
directed but space itself doesn't go
more one way than the other I don't even
know what you mean on the other hand the
person in the street you say you know
time goes from from past to Future
doesn't go from future to past they
again nod at you and say yeah you know
tell me something new
um now I happen to agree with that that
as I think time is fundamentally
different from space temporal structure
is fundamentally different from spatial
structure in the temporal structure does
have a fundamental directionality to it
and spatial structure doesn't this turns
out to be a very contentious view
um among philosophers and physicists for
funny reasons I would say I don't know
that we have the time to go into but it
surely is the minority View
and it's a little bit viewed there's
just a just to clarify it's a little bit
different than there are physicists out
there and philosophers who will question
whether or not time exists or whether
it's fundamental but here we're talking
about the direction the direction time
yes that's right that's right there
there it would be even harder to deny
the existence of time altogether
um but certainly the directionality is
is hotly contested I think time itself
has a direction now it is clearly the
case that there are temporal manifest
temporal asymmetries
on any view if you give me two pictures
of somebody 10 years apart usually I can
look at them and figure oh this was the
younger and this is the older right
because people tend to wrinkle up and
it's like now that's not I mean maybe
they had you know cosmetic surgery I
could get that wrong you know but there
are certainly lots of of very reliable
temporal asymmetries and those need an
explanation simply saying time has a
direction would not explain all by
itself any of those observable temporal
asymmetries are what people sometimes
called arrows of time so I think all of
that is a perfectly good object of study
even if you believe as I do that one of
the things you can you can invoke is
that time is itself directed right that
doesn't give me these observable
asymmetries like that but but it might
be part of the explanation how does it
help
um since people like David Albert and
Barry and myself think that you don't
need an intrinsic Arrow if you just have
a uh initial condition that is doing all
the work well because a lot of the
explanation I mean we can we can do this
in different levels but let me do the
first level
um what do I mean by explaining
something well often I think it's a kind
of causal explanation I talk about cause
and effect and now you say okay but what
distinguishes cause and effect offhand
in many cases causes precede the effects
I mean if people often talk about
running a movie backward or imagining
that which of course you can literally
run a movie backward but then the the
end sequence comes before the title
sequence right you still have a
direction of time
um if you took that seriously as a movie
of something in the normal direction
also all the causal structure would be
reversed right what were causes would
become effects and therefore the
structure of causal explanation would be
different right
um
and so you have to get a bit deep and
and and statistical mechanics does come
into this here in a way that I you know
we couldn't get on the table clearly in
a short period of time where
you not only have causal explanations
where you say this particular precise
physical state gives rise to this later
one but other kinds of statistical
explanations where you say this kind of
physical state not I haven't precisely
but I'm going to constrain it in certain
ways there's a class of various things
gives rise to this kind of state I mean
this is the sort of thing that you take
a box of gas and you say if you wait a
while it'll eventually relax to an
equilibrium
and that of course shows a
directionality to it because uh from
this initial State you can say in five
minutes It'll be equilibrium if you look
at the equilibrium State at a generic
level a kind of fuzzed out level you
couldn't say oh five minutes ago it was
in this non-equilibrium state so the
kind of asymmetry there and that's
connected to certain asymmetries in call
in statistical explanation probabilistic
explanation
it's very interesting and deep hard
topic a bit different than worrying
about say relativity which you might say
is about space-time structure quantum
mechanics is about material structure
statistical explanation is about a kind
of explanatory project and what goes
into it and what succeeds as giving
statistical explanations of things but I
do think that
um reversing the direction of time
you might have a very good what you
consider to be a very good statistical
explanation of something as seen as it
were in One Direction of time and if you
look at the other direction you say wait
there's no explanation at all the
exponent explanatory part went away
um all I can say is a massive
coincidence
or else to be teleological and say the
future is somehow but you know the
future is somehow affecting the present
but I I take it to be one of the great
discoveries of the Scientific Revolution
to get rid of that kind of teleology
does your view that time has an
intrinsic Direction affect what we would
call microphysics the standard model of
particle physics for example or could it
um sure it could I I mean I think that
it it it plays into your fundamental
pictures Face Time structure and and of
course one needs
an account of space-time structure to
even begin to write down what you think
of as well as a physics
um and I think they're very specific
ways in which having a direction well
certainly having a direction well let me
just give you a very concrete thing one
could say
um so suppose I have a kind of grid like
a street grid and I have uh two points
on it and you ask me okay how many
continuous paths are there that will
take me from A to B and typically the
answer if the grid goes on forever it's
infinitely many because it can go short
way or around or far around go way out
and come back
now suppose I put some arrows on that
grid right so they're one-way streets
now it's not at all clear that that this
number will always be infinite now it
might be quite tightly constrained the
directionality gives me a resource there
that a lack of directionality doesn't
have and I think that's actually quite
important and and plays out in trying to
understand the laws of physics but it's
much more complicated it's much more
common but that's what you're thinking
about these days that's one of the
things I'm thinking about very hard I
mean I've been working on thinking about
what space at time could be like if they
were actually not continuous but
discrete at fundamental scale I worked a
long time and did six chapters just on
space and now I have to bring in time
and the time part really has to have a
Direction Just for it to work it has to
have a direction and you have to
understand how the directionality comes
what do you say for it to work for this
for this scheme I have to be a kind of
thing where you could do a plausible
looking sort of physics with do you have
a catchy name for your scheme uh yeah
full discrete geometry full discrete
geometry okay good and the time
directedness has to be part of it it's
fundamental in it yeah okay all right
good well we're looking forward to that
yeah
[Laughter]
come up on chapter eight now I mean the
spatial part went real well and then it
was like okay part two let's bring in
time and then you realize it's a tricky
business
this is all this is all classical
geometry but Quantum field Theory there
is a connection to Quantum field Theory
which I'll just State briefly we talked
about problems just in doing Quantum
field Theory just mathematical problems
one way that this kind of bohmian or
Pilot wave approach fruit Quantum field
theory was done was done by Bell it's
called Bell type Quantum field Theory
and one thing he does is he puts it on a
lattice that is he doesn't do it in
continuous space he does it on a kind of
discrete lattice and you have these
jumps from lattice points to lattice
points that turns out to be very
important to have a structure where you
can do the math in a clean way
okay looking forward to the book coming
out we will pre-advertise it here so
here's the last I'm not even call it a
question thing to respond to
you when we talk about quantum mechanics
and as we say you have to give up
something maybe that was it was hopeful
or intuitive or whatever and even in
relativity uh it seems like maybe the
world is a little bit different is there
hope for fundamentally understanding why
the world is this way like in retrospect
can you say oh yes it had to be quantum
mechanics or are we just stuck with it
yeah I I think people like to say that
why the quantum you know you'll get this
thing I I think oh come come on just you
know grow up no I mean that there's
gonna be foundations there's gonna be
the and one of the really hard questions
in this whole topic is the question
where do I stop digging
right where is my Spade turned where do
I say okay I've hit a foundation here
it looks like this is a plausible place
to stop and all you can say is yeah this
this is the way it is
could it have been some other way yeah
it could have been some other way it
isn't this looks like a plausible place
to stop if you think if you're never
gonna be satisfied okay then you're
never going to be satisfied and the
problem is there are dangers in both
directions right if you're too easily
satisfied you'll stop digging when in
fact you could discover a lot of
interesting structure lying underneath
where you've stopped but if you're too
pig-headed you're gonna get to the
bottom and still be banging your head
against it forever because there is
nothing underneath it right so there's a
kind of you know connoisseur's feel for
where's a reasonable place to stop but I
don't think you're going to be stopped
by some master
principle that says it could only have
been this way
I how could you expect that the world is
kind of contingent well that seems like
a reasonable place to stop so Tim well
then thanks very much can I actually
before you do that because I'm here and
yes and I'm have many voices many years
than I ever kind of normally will have
and I'm going to just take advantage of
you and say
um one of the things I'm doing is trying
to promote foundations of physics and
whatever and doing it is I've founded
this thing called the John Bell
Institute for the foundations of physics
and we are at the very moment a kind of
critical moment where we're trying to
buy a physical place for us to live and
if anybody out there likes people who
talk about this stuff and thinks they
should have a place to go where they can
meet and talk to each other we have a
GoFundMe or you could go to
www.w.johnbellinstitute.org if anybody
would like to help us out in any way
it's our moment of need and uh would
appreciate it greatly good to be
reminded of that I will also mention
that in the intro and put links on the
web page I can mention to because it's
an audio podcast Tim is wearing a very
fetching John Bell Institute polo shirt
right now so that could be swag I don't
know is that a GoFundMe no this this to
get the shirt you got to come to the
place the only the only the only
exception to that are my parents who are
95 and I said you can have shirts
without actually going but this is this
you can only wear the shirt if you've
been there and you've seen this
beautiful island in Croatia and enjoyed
it and then you get a shirt but it is it
is actually an important thing I'm glad
you mentioned it because it's a reminder
that ideas are great and conversations
about them are great but institutions
also matter for getting these ideas out
and this is the problem is this field is
a is an academic orphan yeah right
foundations of physics doesn't fit
I mean it kind of doesn't fit in physics
departments and it doesn't really fit in
philosophy departments and so you know
if it's going to live a place has to be
made for it all right let's look it up
on the on the internet so in that case
thanks very much for being on my skate
podcast thank you
[Music]
foreign